we haven't ever had anybody work you
work with on set you don't have to say
the name obviously but somebody you're
like he needs to be smacked around a few
times
how do you keep your cool because you're
a tough guy well you don't you don't
like people getting picked on you don't
like yeah you don't like bullies you
don't like you know you just walk over
to him and say hey man we're done let's
just go outside
nobody just me and you will go outside
like to talk yeah no no no we'll go
outside you know you want to be this way
we'll go outside you've said that oh
what do they say I believe more times
than they've never done it never never
when you say that no 99 of the people
out there do not want an altercation nor
do I I mean I don't you know I don't
train to be to fight in the street like
I train because I love it